[Musique]
bonsoir nos amis 11 oh la la
que de bruit chez nicolas et pimprenelle
qui s'exerce avec laure pipeau pas trop
mais c'est très bien ça mais il n'est
pas nécessaire de souffler aussi fort
dans les pipots pour faire de la belle
musique descend vite leur dire qu'il ne
faut pas faire tant de bruit nounours
boulou seul cheveu et hop hop hop hop
hop hop bonsoir ou non il ne faut pas
tout ceci fort où l'eau où l'alors en
trop il faut faire très bien les enfants
bravo je vois que vous savez très bien
faire do ré mi fa sol la si do alors
maintenant écoutez bien
[Musique]
il
nul ici
et puis
c'est fou
si si
beaucoup
il
[Rires]
au clair de la lune
mon ami pierrot prête-moi ta plume
l'offre du don c'est comme ça
[Musique]
non pas preneur c'est comme ça au clair
de lune
mon ami pierrot prête moi ta plume pour
écrire un mot oui c'était non les
enfants regardent et je vais vous moquer
mais pitot n'est pas de nous bon bon eh
bien c'est l'heure d'aller houle est pas
très bon ça non alors
[Musique]
je ne suis pas fait pour les instruments
à vous écouter
[Musique]
non c'est mieux alors c'est très amusant
de jouer du pipeau
le ce soir se fit ne m'avoue pour et
enjouée toute l'info fait bord est le
petit 2
bonne mine et pas la peau nue par boonen
thor bien bonne nuit les enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents en
dormez-vous vite et fait de bourrel à te
voilà grands musiciens me voient l'offre
en route mon nounours
bonne nuit à demain comme ball bleue
[Musique]
oh
o o
[Musique]